[Music]
you know there's only been two or three
times in my career 30 years here on the
air that elizabeth warren and i have
agreed on something
and uh because i'm a capitalist pig and
she's a socialist
um and uh she's a very bright lady and
i've actually had her on the air here
back in the day we were fighting a
bankruptcy bill that the republicans put
through
uh at the behest of the bankers and it
was a bad bill and it's a bad law and
it's still in place uh modification is
the bankruptcy law and she and i were on
the same side of that ted kennedy was
the three of us were fighting against
that and we all lost of course uh and
but she's come out today and and of
course if you haven't heard
uh navient uh six million student loan
borrowers are far better off after yet
another major company announced it will
shut down its services elizabeth warren
said like like elizabeth warren calls
navient to shut down come on elizabeth
you didn't cause this but yeah no one uh
no one is crying a tear that navient is
gone navient one of the largest student
loan companies unveiled plans to end its
federal loan services the student loan
industry on tuesday received yet another
major shakeup when navient became the
third company to announce
its plans to end its federal student
loan program amid regulatory crackdowns
this year
senator elizabeth warren had one message
for the company good riddance i would
agree with you senator warren navient
has spent decades misleading cheating
and abusing student borrowers
the federal student loan program will be
far better off without them
the federal student loan program would
be far better off if it didn't exist
senator warren it has not been a
blessing to anyone except people like
navient and people like you
who used it to get votes
navient which collects the federal
student loan debt of 6 million borrowers
said in a press release that it's
working with the education department to
approve the transition of those
borrowers to another loan company called
maximus that's it that's a villainous
comforting
that's a comforting maximus what
interest
maximus interest that's scary
maximus screw job
so you just get traded to the next one
can't make this up
they're gonna call it maximus
oh boy this is fabulous
this is what's wild richard cordray head
of the federal student aid office he
said earlier this month student loan
companies are choosing to shut down
rather than face more accountability
yeah that's what's going on because
they've been screwing people they go hey
this ship is sinking let's get out of
here well we we don't got caught with
our hand in the cookie jar we got all
the cookies out of this we're gonna get
we're gone baby we're gonna get out of
here before we end up the subject of a
federal investigation and get more than
shut down yeah that's what that's what's
going on they're not doing anyone favors
but themselves here yeah and i gotta
tell you the democrats and the
republicans uh did put pressure on
navient for its misbehavior and thank
you i will go along with you senator
warren uh good riddance to naviant
ciao baby
student loans we're bringing people from
across the aisle today bring all maximus
bring our maximus
maximus interests